Movies aren’t always designed to be easy
to understand.
Sometimes, it’s your own fault for not paying
more attention.
But there are also times when the entire audience
just doesn’t get it.
Here are a few scenes that needed a little
bit of extra explaining...
Donnie Darko
Fact: nobody understood Donnie Darko the first
time around—especially the insane ending.
It’s the world.
Because… well, alternate reality time travel
stuff.
It’s all explained in the director’s cut,
but some viewers believe that Donnie didn’t
actually have to die to save the world, and
that sending the jet engine through time was
enough.
Death isn’t inevitable, but Donnie knows
what’s going to happen.
He lets himself die because he feels at peace
by the time all of his alternate universe
time travel shenanigans are over.
One-ness with the universe or not, that bunny
was still pretty freaky.
Star Trek
During the climax of J.J. Abrams' Star Trek,
Spock ignites a black hole inside the villain's’
ship, and this scene plays out.
“The ship is compromised, the ship is too
close to the singularity to survive without
assistance which we are willing to provide.”
“Captain, what are you doing?”
“Show them compassion maybe the only way
to earn peace with the Romulans.
It’s logic Spock.
THought you would like that.”
“No, not really.”
Confused viewers had to wonder: is Spock giving
in to human emotions?
Those bad guys had previously destroyed Spock's
homeworld and killed his family, after all.
But Spock’s behavior is actually 100% Vulcan.
Early in the movie, young Spock learns the
ethical concept of "supererogation," or as
they define it:
“When is it morally praiseworthy but not
morally obligatory.”
Most viewers didn't remember the earlier Vulcan
school scene… but that black hole business?
Pure Vulcan ethics.
“Fascinating”
Total Recall
Arnold Schwarzenegger plays a man named Douglas
Quaid who visits a company to have artificial
memories of a secret agent adventure implanted
in his brain, but something goes wrong.
Turns out that Quaid is really a sleeper agent,
and the fake memory process starts to reactivate
his real memories.
Or is that just part of the imaginary adventure?
“If I am not me,who the hell am I?”
Director Paul Verhoeven put the true answer
in the movie.
During the final shot, Quaid stands on the
mountains of Mars, and there's a bright flash
from the sun.
So, the initial procedure actually did go
terribly wrong.
Happy ending?
Nope.
It’s a doctor cutting into a man's wrecked
brain.
“I have a headache.”
“It might be a tumor?”
“It’s not a tumor.”
American Psycho
Patrick Bateman is a man who spends his nights
committing increasingly vile acts of violence.
“Hey Paul, AHHHHH”
He emotionlessly narrates his experiences,
making statements like, well…
“I simply am not there”
Eventually, he calls his lawyer and leaves
a message confessing to his crimes, but when
he confronts his lawyer in person, he doesn't
even recognize Bateman.
Fans have debated whether or not Bateman’s
murders are actually real.
But according to director Mary Harmon, the
point of the lawyer scene isn't to cast doubt
on Bateman's murders, but to emphasize that
it doesn't matter.
Whatever Bateman is, he's normal.
Wall Street, and the whole world, is full
of self-involved psychopaths.
How’s that for bleak?
Lost in Translation
An aging movie star named Bob meets Charlotte,
a married woman, and the two of them connect
deeply.
Lost in Translation ends with the them about
to part ways forever, when Bob runs to find
Charlotte.
They hug, and he whispers something in her
ear before leaving.
Most assumed that this was a romantic ending,
but it was meant to be heartbreaking.
In the original script, Bob tells Charlotte
to stay with her husband, unable to tell her
that he loves her.
Honestly, we preferred the mystery.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
movie endings you’d like to see explained...